les indiens originaires du sri lanka ce
sont les premiers tisaneurs à connaître
les vertus de la citronnelle une herbe
pourvu de longues tiges vertes qui
dégagent une délicate odeur citronnée
canton les froisse les indiens se
serviront de ces à rome pour parfumer
leurs plats traditionnels mais également
distillation pour en faire de l'huile
essentielle la citronnelle est également
une plante utilisée pour ses propriétés
médicinales
la coupe est
presque pour bien faire bourgeonner si
un coup de trop et c'est pas bon parce
que la planche d'appel de la force
beaucoup de bien à 5 qui cm
la souche est bien là d'une reprise de
pouce après facilité
une plantes à parfum donc se dire huiles
essentielles possibilité de distillation
est sortie elle est essentielle si on
est là cette scission dans l'inconnu à
la réunion en trouve un peu partout dans
les coûts dans les jardins plantés en
bordure là où c'est qu'on élève les
abeilles la bei sont particulièrement
gâtés avec ce parfum non parce que ça
les attire et ça les calme pour les
personnes qui utilisent ça c'est vrai
que c'est la réunion on a l'habitude
d'utiliser tout ça plante c'est sûr
qu'on agit voilà appris et voilà c'est
le chou on appelle ça le chou de la
citronnelle cse soula qui utilisés pour
les petite tisane la fusion est aussi
dans la cuisine
donc avec le poisson ça se marie bien
sous ces citronnelle
on utilise juge essentiel on peut
l'utiliser à dans du miel pour petits
problèmes de grip aussi on peut
l'utiliser pour problèmes de tous la
citronnelle la petite canne citronnelle
a confirmé fusion c'est pour la grippe
c'est pour la fièvre c'est pour bien
parfumée les petits mais les repas et
et on a sûrement certainement d'autres
d'utilisation on va faire bouillir de
l'eau pour 3,4 à 120 mètres qui bateau
comme ça là en infusion on peut faire
même mieux que ça c'est à dire l'eau à
bouillir les petits bâtons retrouve
coupée comme ça
voilà qui bat en coupe et on laisse ça à
fuser dedans on laisse ça à refuser 20
minutes on était le feu on laisse
infuser on filtre n'oublie pas de
filtrer et on boit sa bonne petite tasse
et digestive aussi s'en va et des
prédictions qui on peut associer ça avec
rom avec la ja pana on peut associer ça
avec la cannelle poutiainen grippe on
peut associer avec
petit coeur de ce is pour tisane fièvre
voilà c'est une petite plante avec les
attentes comme a cité la très connu à la
réunion est très apprécié
la fusion de la pana et d'anis doit bien
manger là et nous va boire ça juste
après pour bien digérer voilà le petit
isard n'est pas née alice à nice bien
mélanger la peut rajouter un petit peu
d'argent là dedans y fera pas de mal
voilà nous les à 5,6 personne n'avait la
dose ou cinq six personnes
nous remettre ça dans un petit
récipient l'un pour verser là dessus de
l'eau que la wii de sawtche au dessus
on va laisser ça voilà la plante l'eau
commence à changer de couleur la voix
bien et ça commence à être parfumée au
sillon sans un bonne tisane
bâti en terre par petites
touches un petit pied comme ça au bout
de trois quatre mois ils commencent
coupé déjà présentes et ont planté fait
une bouture voilà ça c'est une bouture
met en terre vite fait un petit ouf avec
ça dans les bas très rapide dans les
eaux un petit peu plus lent mais voilà
un petit goûter citronnelle
voit la citronnelle
facilement à trouver partout dans l'île
dans les 4000
ça fait de belles et belle petite et qui
retient les terres retient le sol anti
érosifs et c'est facile à planter facile
à trouver des plants ne pas hésiter
d'implanter en bordure ou c'est que on a
des problèmes d'érosion ne pas hésiter à
planter un bon dieu ou sait qu'on a les
abeilles ne pas hésiter à partir une
bonne touche dans la maison dans la cour
ça fait la tisane gratuite ou toute
l'année